[Musik]
hallo mein name ist wohl das schöne
wetter freunde wir schreiben milde 26
grad sonne keine wolke am himmel und ich
fahre nun erstmal ins team
ja okay danke
[Musik]
ich bin tot
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich komme wieder und love is here ihm
wie die ganze zeit schon so amrum tanzen
einfach als wenn der geburtstag gelte ja
sonst irgendwas verschwiegen
herzlichen glückwunsch fluffy hielt ich
weiß nicht was jetzt genau mit diesen
dinge los ist die sache des kieler habe
auch immer in die kommentare geschrieben
dass hier aus endingen haben schlafen
kannst du nicht mal der hat wirklich gut
gemacht du wirst nicht 22 klavier wusste
auch nicht dass du geburtstag hast ja
wie das stand da drin
und warum bist du jetzt abgefuckt
also wenn der lila war angetan hat dann
befindet er sich jetzt in mehreren
kleinen kunstrasen
es befindet sich in phase 4 kleinkind
lavies in der tat jetzt in der kleinen
kind phase angekommen oder flop nachdem
wir jetzt allerdings im gym bahnfreunde
heißt es für uns erstmal natürlich sich
gesund ernähren denn gerade nach wie man
sport gemacht hat sollte man auf seine
ernährung achten sich gesund ernähren in
die ostchinesische gebratener reis mit
server-software schlecht warum brauchen
menschen luft jetzt ist mir noch
schlechter allerdings werde damen und
herren die hat es wahrscheinlich schon
der titel gewesen natürlich sonst hätte
die auch nicht ob das richtig drauf
gekriegt ich rede heute mal wieder welt
genau mit siri ich weiß nicht was mit
fluffy los verkehr wieder schlug auch
nicht richtig kriege
es geht wirklich stufen hopp nicht nur
mich mario aber kocht gerade passt da
für mich leider reicht nicht dass ich
keine weizen produkte es eigentlich auch
gar kein essen zu gehen
[Musik]
warum bin ich so hässlich
darauf kann ich dir echt keine antwort
geben
desiree harry siri hey siri hazy rebe
ich hatte wenig anders also schauen wir
doch das ganze jetzt funktioniert und
zwar reverie wie geht's dir ich fühle
mich spitze sehr schön möchtest du
wissen wie es freude macht gar nicht
weiter möchtest du wissen wie es mir
geht
es gibt hier und luca nicht um mich
deswegen frage ich erhoffe mir geht es
auch super siri bei mir sind entspannte
25 grad gerade hier in bielefeld wie
warum ist es denn bei dir bielefeld etwa
24 grad ist das serie und auch in
bielefeld allerdings werden wir heute
nicht normal mit sie operierten und sie
irgendetwas fragen über ihr leben oder
keine ahnung was erst mal hallo juli
wir beide haben uns einige sachen
rausgesucht die man sich einfach mal
fragen könnte wo es eventuell
interessant wäre weil die antwort zu
hören was ist dein lieblingstier
ich glaube sind mein tigerenten genau
siri wachstum hunde billiger bündig hier
wagst du basketball zu schauen sich mit
dem basketball gelegen
das hier hat willi hat wirklich gerade
einfach alles vorleser für die ganze
zeit
magst du fußball aber ich kann gern
infos zu vergangenen spielen heraus
warum hat die basketball so einen coolen
job beim fußball gar nix tragt euch
übrigens nicht warum hier vorne seine
matratze steht mir wollte das eigentlich
absaugen aber haben das bisher nicht
geschafft weil wir sind frauen im
nächsten block sind julia die ich
übrigens auch wieder in köln
da werden dann wieder ein bisschen kraft
nein ich bin jetzt immer noch scheiße
bleiben wir haben sie noch gar nicht so
richtig gefragt was überhaupt gerade
macht also wir was machst du gerade
ach ich antworte plus auf drei millionen
leute die alle gleichzeitig resi rufen
siri ist richtig gut multitasking im
gegensatz zu mir was ist überhaupt deine
lieblingsfarbe alles klar
meine grenzen es ist überhaupt der blick
ins tal gerade dann soll ich das
überhaupt weglassen also siri waffe ist
eine lieblingsfarbe eine den kings tag
ist na ja wie soll ich das in deiner
sprache ausdrückt eine art grünen aber
mit mehr die versionen
ich kann ein grün mehrere dimensionen
eine frage die man sich eigentlich so
gar nicht stellt weil man das denkt weil
sie standardmäßig diese sprache
eigentlich haben wir für diesen tod aber
auch sie überhaupt eine frau ist weil
man kann ja auch eine männer sprache
glaube ich einstellen siri bist du eine
frau ich geräte nämlich nach eigentlich
kukksi ist einfach so etwas ich bin siri
dahinter zu assistent ich mache jetzt
mal männlich eine ewigkeit später musste
die gerade jetzt erstmal die menschliche
sprache für sie liegen aber ich kann
jetzt einfach mal mit siri lebenden
dennoch meldet antworten notwendig wo
ich herkomme kann jeder sein was er
möchte ist okay wir glaubst du an gott
das frage ich mich auch oft ist es war
komisch an seiner person hin zu reden
die räte normalerweise diese sie
richtete aber der hier ist irgendwie in
cannes zu fliegen
nein das kann ich nicht und werden bei
der eltern
ich habe doch dich
allerdings lagen zu einer frage die ich
persönlich mir schon sein dänischer
reifen besitzen betriebsergebnis jährige
geschädigte frage magst du pizza es geht
und ich locker richtig warum kann er mir
so dass ich einfach mal beantworten wer
hat dich gemacht
es steht darauf den karton ich wurde von
apple in kalifornien entwickelt ja aber
wer sind deine eltern
es gibt nur durch uns recht du bist
wirklich das ist ja cool wird barry sag
mir was ich mutiges der teppich müsst
ihr mal wieder gesagt werden das stück
wer ist die schönste
[Musik]
also wir wissen jetzt dass syrien nicht
männlich ist aber auch nicht weiblich
wir wissen dass sie ihre keine eltern
hat und es einfach nur in kalifornien
nicht aufgewachsen ist sondern
entwickelt wurde was wir allerdings
nicht wissen ist wie sie die aus pavilly
wie siehst du aus er sieht genau aus
hast du etwas an
es geht hier um dich nicht mich dass er
nicht einfach meine frage was hast du an
mal gucken dachte ich mir doch das
gleiche wie gestern
stimmst du dann ich bin foul an kuta
faulheit ist heilbar aber die behandlung
ist sehr aufwändig also ich kann es
heilen dass ich das nicht nicht mehr
faul bin ich finde dich cool wie hast du
heute gut geschlafen ich fürchte ich
kann das nicht beantworten warum kann
das nicht beantworten dir die ganze zeit
frage ich nicht geben was und ich möchte
einfach dass du mir ehrlich und richtig
antwortet du bist fragen immer aus dem
weg und so weiter und so fort also siri
warum kannst du dich einfach ehrlich mir
gegenüber sein
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das
richtig verstanden habe
ich bin siri ist es halt wirklich so ich
nehme mir vorher um ich rede heute mal
wieder mit ihr so ich habe ja schon
öfters mit ihr geredet an der videos
haben unfassbar viele aufrufe alle sagen
immer helga den verwirrten serie und
dann denke ich mir es geht gut los und
dann weil sie ab dem moment einfach
nicht mehr richtig was sie sagen soll
und sagt mir hey das geht mich nichts an
es geht hier um dich luca will ich warte
jetzt auf jeden fall darauf dass meine
alte habe ich mich gerade schrauben
warum stehst du vor der tür
alles klar danke für die antwort juden
nicht warten jetzt auf jeden fall darauf
dass meine schwester ab und leider den
geburtstag von sandra fahren
falls ihr sagen auch nicht kennt hier
ein kurzer ausschnitt irgendwie die
kirche sowieso ein strand geld für mich
mal nicht verbunden
auf dem weg zu sandra hat zusammen mit
sarah hier die netterweise fährt für uns
zusammen mit jule hinten einfach ihre
kappe hält wir haben kein geschenk für
sandra hast du dich eigentlich über das
geschenk von uns für dich gefreut war
gerade auf sanders geburtstagsparty bzw
das heißt party cover von nur geschält
und gelaber und eine menge pizza
gegessen
wir stehen einfach an in seiner straße
und die visite wollte mich nach hause
doch wir können kmu machen
die wm läuft das zweite jahr lang gibt
keinen kabul seit dem deutschland bei
der werbe übrigens ausgeschiedene
supported jule
warum eigentlich
aber wir sind trotzdem irgendwie solchen
hüte damit der hund in der pfanne
verrückt zu diesen dummen job bin ich
mit diesem scheiß leckerli durch den
ganzen supermarkt gelaufen ich leide für
malta die haben schon die neuen jesus
hier jetzt im supermarkt für eine
viertelstunde und das einzige was wir
gekauft haben ist ein nein danke
heliumballon
das sind spaß deines lebens wird sexy
pendant geschockt da hinten gerade noch
ein bisschen
ich will gleich nochmal mit ballonen
bisschen gassi gehen beine und po
ich wollte allerdings noch mal ganz kurz
auf ein paar kommentare unter dem
letzten block in eurem zwar nicht
explizit auf einzelne kommentare
allerdings habe ich gesehen dass einige
leute geschrieben haben hey luca also
top 10 arten beziehungen oder sauce
jedoch nicht auf das niveau von bibi
oder keine ahnung wem runter ich weiß
ist dass ich ein bisschen anders war
also diese anderen typischen luca blogs
oder luca videos sage ich jetzt mal und
es tut mir auch leid falls damit nicht
den geschmack von jedermann getroffen
habe allerdings wo ich das einfach mal
ausprobieren und ich fand es jetzt auch
eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm ich war
das video dienstag 24 stunden über eine
million aufrufe das ist natürlich sehr
sehr krass und sehr viel für meine
verhältnisse allerdings habe ich halt
auch gesehen dass einige negative
kommentare da waren und auch irgendwie
5000 dislike natürlich auch über 80.000
likes aber man konzentriert sich ja
irgendwie nur auf die negativen sachen
deswegen werde ich versuchen in den
nächsten block so ein bisschen mehr
typische 'ran luca content zu machen zum
beispiel nächsten blogs sind wir wieder
in köln
und da habe ich auch schon da ist die
idee was wir da machen werden aber
wartet einfach mal ab freunde dieses
neue konzept auf einem kanal mit
dieselloks
viele denken dass jetzt nur noch blogs
kommen auf einem kanal natürlich ist das
erst mal so der plan aber in diesem
blogs kann ja auch mal gaming kommen und
viele haben als so bemängelt der halo
kann doch kein game mehr da kommt nicht
mehr die ist nicht mehr das natürlich
deswegen mache ich das doch das kann
trotzdem noch vorkommen gibt dem ganzen
einfach mal die chance wartet mal ab
ende juli genau sagen allerdings will
ich an der stelle der heutigen blog
jetzt auch beenden ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wenn sie das getan hat das
gerne mal einen laib da wir sehen uns
über wochen in einem neuen blog wieder
und jule
[Musik]